today we're reviewing the nvidia rtx
3060 ti
because nvidia has decided that there
needs to be more products on the market
with gpus than that so we're reviewing
the 360 ti it's been a lot of gpu
reviews lately
we're still however going to look at a
pretty full suite of tests frequency
thermals noise and rpm and then of
course games and rtx games
we have cut a couple of tests from this
because it's been non-stop gpus for
several months now but this is still a
pretty full featured review
of the 3060 ti which is supposed to be a
400 video card
for the floor msrp pricing before that
this video is brought to you by thermal
grizzlies conductor not liquid metal
conductive knot is what we've used in
all of our liquid metal and delid
thermal tests capable of dropping cpu
thermals significantly when replacing
the stock thermal interface
lower cpu thermals don't just allow
better overclocks but also lower noise
levels because the transfer efficiency
is increased
the mix of gallium and indium makes for
a thermal conductivity of 73 watts per
meter kelvin
outclassing traditional pastes
significantly learn more at the link in
the description below
so the 3060 ti we're again starting with
the founders edition model
it's the nvidia card which is supposed
to be 400 dollars
the partner models we're not so sure
what the pricing is going to look like
for those assuming you can get them
where at the point you can get them
anyway
because it sounds like the pricing is
somewhat unachievable for a good cooler
and maintaining that pricing in the long
term past the expiry of
say mdf for example a rebates or or
other
modes of getting uh discounts on the
supply from nvidia
anyway whatever the pricing ends up
being for the partner models
the fe card we're reviewing is a 400
model the fe 3070
is 500 the rx 6800 reference
is supposed to be 580 and then you've
got the
6800 xt and the 3080s and a different
price class
all together the weird thing though
about the 3060 ti
reviewing it that is is that it doesn't
have a direct competitor from this
generation so we don't have
an amd card in the 400 price class yet
which makes it a bit of an awkward
comparison because
the closest amd card that makes sense
would be the 6800
and that's a lot more money the
nvidia cards there aren't any other
lower end ones there's no 3069 ti
there's no 30 50 yet
and those will be coming out at some
point but probably not until next year
since we're so close to the end
of this one so that makes the 3060 ti
review a little awkward because
it's it's sort of like a well if you're
trying to spend 400
then i guess this is it this is the one
you can buy it
uh or you can spend 100 plus dollars
more which is
probably not feasible for most people
planning to spend 400
on a card nonetheless though in the very
least we'll be able to help you decide
if spending an extra hundred dollars
would even be worth it for you
if you were considering say a price
floor 3070. so we're going to keep this
one fairly simple in terms of reviews
just because
we've done a lot of gpu reviews now
where we need to sort of do some other
reviews at this point
and so we've trimmed a couple of charts
but all the stuff you need still in
there especially the gaming stuff
some overclocking as well overclocking
as a quick four note here
was fairly successful on the card but
the actual
gains from it were highly variable
sometimes it was
uh unstable the clocks that we chose and
some of the games and other times you
got a 10 uplift uh 12
of the highest case which is absolutely
huge for an osu
uplift but with a little bit more time
we could tune it some more we'd probably
have to walk it back you'll see that in
the oc stepping charts though but before
getting into the review charts
a reminder on smart access memory and
sam testing
we ran as part of the 6800xt review we
ran
a series of smart access memory tests
with the amd card
nvidia does not yet have the pcie
resizable bar feature
for its 30 series it's planning to roll
that out
and it's planning to have it be platform
neutral but it hasn't done it yet so amd
is still the only company that has
the pcie resizable base address register
via sam that we already tested
we have not rerun all of the tests on an
amd platform at this time but we will
once we do our next refactoring of gpu
benchmarks
uh but for now if you want the full sam
impact you can check our 6800xt review
it is anywhere from zero percent
to a couple percent on average with the
outlier being about a 10 uplift in
hitman 2
but that won't be in here and uh since
the 6800 is so distant in price anyway
doesn't really matter so we're gonna
walk through it with what we have you
checked sam benchmarks and the previous
content we've removed the 3090 from a
lot of the game charts because it's
so it's not particularly relevant let's
get into it we've got a lot of numbers
to go through
so we'll get started we always start
with a frequency plot to validate that
the devices we're testing are working
properly we're looping a 3d mark frame
on repeat to
test the frequency response for this one
ideally you'd see a flat line but that's
not really what we encounter in the real
world
typically you get a flat line when
you've got a high-end air cooler or more
likely a liquid cooler
and boosted power targets with that in
this chart for the founders edition 360
ti
we see what we expect which is a brief
peek at the very beginning
and then an immediate frequency decay
and fall off to a steady state frequency
of about 1950 megahertz
this next chart is zoomed in to help aid
with the comparison between other 30
series gpus
the 3060 ti plots first and also highest
for its average sustained frequency next
the rtx 3070 fe plots at what will
become the bottom of this chart
at about 1914 megahertz average the 3080
fe
fills in the middle this is somewhat
expected behavior at this point
where lower end nvidia gpus often have
very minor clock advantages
over their immediate next larger size
die counterpart
but they drop hardware level
improvements in exchange for that by
nature of going to a smaller die size
the net result is that clearly a 3060 ti
will still be worse than the other two
in terms of raw performance
but it's able to take advantage of
improved stability at higher clocks
due to reduced hardware complexity and
close a bit of the gap
as far as it can anyway without
increasing the uh the gpu complexity or
skew we often do noise normalized
testing to determine the efficiency and
advantages of various models of the same
gpu like partner cards
so the best could then be chosen among
them when it comes to a new
fe card though since it's basically
launching in a vacuum until we get the
partner models to test against
we don't have anything to compare to yet
so we run under auto conditions to learn
about the v
bio cpu temperature targets and the fan
ramp behavior
this can also help with studying fan
hysteresis in some cards as well
where sometimes it's a little bit too
latent and you get an acoustic response
that is
overbearing in some of the cards we've
looked at running the same frozen frame
repeat render from the previous chart
the rtx 3060 ti
holds about 70 degrees celsius here
which is a mix of ambient conditions of
21c
and the v bios temperature targets and
of course the fan curve
thermally that's fine we'll need to look
at gddr and vrm component temperatures
to see how the
less frequently monitored aspects of the
gpu do but we'll probably save that for
the partner comparisons
as for the fan behavior that ramps at a
similar pace to the gpu temperature ramp
there isn't much of an initial delay or
lag for the fan to start spinning which
is
typically a good thing and it spins up
to about 1600 rpm to sustain the 70
degree temperature before
getting into the games and overclocking
here's a quick noise chart
the fans are the same as the 3070 fe and
the noise levels are there for the same
so this chart applies to both the 30
70 fe and 3060 ti fe the noise level in
our auto v bios conditions previously
shown would put us at about 34 dba at 20
inch distance
so nvidia has room for more aggression
on the fan if it wants
but it's a well-balanced thermal and
noise configuration for this specific
model
partner cards of course will likely out
do this in many instances
but uh overall this seems fine our
overclock stepping table shows the raw
notes for the process of overclocking
the 3060 ti
this is how we take notes while walking
through the oc process and it just helps
us keep track of things
it includes port royal scores on the far
right as a means of validating whether
the performance
improved or decayed the latter of which
can happen if you have error correction
on the memory from
running an unstable memory clock or just
unstable core clocks that
appear stable because it's completing
the test but might actually be nuking
the performance
the temperature column isn't that useful
here and you shouldn't be taking it as a
measure of thermal performance the
previous charts did that it's only there
to correlate against
the frequency which change based on
thermals
but because these tests are constantly
crashing or restarting
there's no constant load and so the
temperature chart isn't meant to be used
that way
the stock test had the frequency at 1875
to 1920 megahertz at initial run
and we typically do a time spy extreme
looping test
for stress test for initial validation
then run
port royal it fell to 1860 to 1890
megahertz after a few minutes
and we found that a range of 2040 to
2085 megahertz was possible to run and
appeared stable
including a 1200 megahertz memory offset
but technically it offered no
improvement
over the 1 000 megahertz memory offset
of the previous run
7314 points over 6709
means a nine percent performance uplift
in this rt heavy benchmark
power was still the primary limiter as
expected and this is where partner cards
could potentially offer an advantage
the memory on the 3060 ti for our
overclocking though was ridiculous
we suspect we got lucky on the draw with
this one
because this kind of offset and oc
performance
on uh just a reference well an fe board
is not common and ours happen to scale
very well
we did have to drop it a little bit for
horizon zero dawn
because it wasn't as stable in that game
as it was in the others
but you'll see that in the game
benchmarks this next chart is for a
shadow of the tomb raider at 4k
we'll bring down the resolution as we go
for each game the rtx 3060 ti held 59
fps average with these settings
rtx off here with lows paced well behind
at 54 and 53 fps
we have no frame pacing issues on the
360 ti for this 4k benchmark
so things are looking good the 2080
super is just above the 360 ti
and within run to run variants the
overclock didn't do much for us giving
us a 3.7 percent
uplift from the oc 360 ti to the stock
one
the stock 3060 ti is about 14.8 percent
better than the 5700 xt tai chi x from
the previous amd generation it's 16.6
ahead of the 1080 ti stock for the ftw3
model
and it's 55 ahead of the rtx ko as for
the 3070 the 66 fps average
isn't really game changing here but is a
substantial improvement in pure
percentage
of 11 the rx 6800 stock card ran 81 fps
average for this one and that's a 37
percent uplift over the 30 60 ti
in exchange for 180 more against msrp
but partner models for nvidia and amd
obfuscate what the actual price is for
these either way though
it's at least for now a meaningful
uplift in this game
in exchange for a lot more money at
1440p tomb raider has the 3060 ti
at 105 fps average which ranks it
hierarchically the same as compared to
the 2080 super
and the 5700 xt the 3070 maintains an 11
lead as before and the rx 6800 maintains
a lead of 34
there's a slight reduction in the 6800
leadership over the 3060 ti
but most of the rest of the numbers
remain comparable at 1080p the 3060 ti
maintains a 150 fps average with lows
again reasonably spaced
the 3060 ti oc gains 2.6 over stock
proving unworthy of the time the 3070 fe
keeps exactly an 11
lead over the ti stock once again and
the rx 6800 positions itself 16
ahead it's weird reviewing a gpu that
once again does not have a direct modern
competitor
it's an upgrade from the 20 series yes
but not in a way that demands a new
purchase moving from the 900 series
might make more sense
but moving from the 20 series probably
just keep using it for a little while
longer
next up is red dead redemption 2 with
dx12 and at 4k we'll look at dx12 versus
vulcan scaling momentarily as we test
both apis right now
the rtx 3060 ti fe stock card held
57 fps average here climbing 3 to 59 fps
average with an overclock
the 3070 fe stock card holds a 10.5
percent lead
consistent now with tomb raider and the
regular 11
uplift over the 30 60 ti the rx 6800
maintains a 15
lead compared to the 20 series the 30 60
ti
out does the 2080 super stock and
everything below it
including the rtx 2060 ko which is
outdone by 60
with the 3060 ti moving to 1440p the rtx
360 ti fe stock card ran 93 fps average
our oc didn't move the bar here because
it wasn't stable enough which is a
casualty
of being overrun with too many reviews
so we've removed it from the results to
reduce confusion
the 3070 fe leads the 3060 ti fe
by 10 fps or about 10.4 percent the 3060
ti
leads the 2060 ko by 54
1080 ti ftw 3 stock is led by 31
with the new 360 ti in the lead of that
and the 2080 super is led by the 3060 ti
by 8 the rx 6800 meanwhile leads the 360
ti by 20
at 1080p the 360 ti stock card held 113
fps average with nothing to show from
our overclock
we likely need to walk it back a little
bit it's at 116 fps average here the 113
fps average for stock allows the 3070 fe
lead of eight and a half percent reduced
from
some of the previous and higher
resolution benchmarks the 3070 and 3080
as we've seen in the past
tend to expand their lead as the
resolution increases especially as it
approaches or reaches 4k
the rx 6800 holds a 20.4 lead here over
the 360 ti
which is almost identical to its 20 lead
in
and the hierarchical positioning in the
1440p tests
in terms of the vulcan versus dx12
scaling numbers
here it is the rx 6800 and 6800xt
lost performance in vulkan at a 1.2
percent
or two and a half percent reduction
while the 3060 ti
and modern nvidia cards improve in
vulcan the vulcan improvements move the
3060 ti
6.5 ahead of its dx12 positioning
keeping in mind that
the two apis don't necessarily draw the
same thing
so it might not be a pure like for like
and probably isn't
we don't have the development tools to
really determine that total war 3
kingdoms is next
starting at 4k the rtx 360 ti plotted 29
fps average here
but we run unreasonably high settings at
ultra
which allows us to get some long-term
scaling comparisons for the future
as cards advance it's still interesting
because the memory utilization with this
configuration is
exceptionally high the rtx 3070 is 33
fps average led the 360 ti by 15.4
percent
the rx 6800 led it by 30 so we've gained
a little bit versus the
1440 and 1080 numbers in red dead and
the
3080 led the 360 ti by 64 percent here
at 1440p we reach a more playable 58 fps
average in the battle benchmark with the
lows paced proportionally behind
relative to nvidia cards but
they're worse than pacing relative to
the 5700 xt
or the rx 68 and 68 xd cards
the rtx 3060 ti stock card held
a 13 lead over the 1080 ti ftw 3 stock
card
47 percent lead over the 2060 ko
and it was led by the rtx 3070 fe by
15.2 percent
the rx 6800 is further ahead still
keeping pace with the 4k comparisons
so far it looks like the 3070s lead
expanded a little bit up to 15
from an average of 11 in shadow of the
tomb raider for this game
and if you're looking at these numbers
worried that you won't be able to get to
the fps you want in this game
keep in mind that we're testing with
ultra settings the hierarchy will remain
about the same but the fps will increase
if you're willing to drop your settings
down to something more reasonable like
high at 1080p the rtx 3060 ti pushes to
92 fps average with a real gain
finally to be had from our 360 ti feoc
the overclock allowed us an uplift of 12
percent which is huge when compared to
the average oc uplift for
the rest of this series it seemed to
help us more at 1080p than
elsewhere for this game as well this
also allows the 3060 ti to reach 30 70
fe stock levels
which was around 105 fps average stock
to stock though the 30 70 fe still leads
the 30 60 ti by about 14
but again that gap closes with the oc
the rx 6800 122 fps average holds a 32
advantage over the 30 60 ti stock card
in this one
lifted up over some of the other games
we're gonna start going through these
charts faster now that a clear trend has
been established
you can pause if you need to look at the
older cards more closely
horizon zero dawn is next at 4k the oc
does nothing for us and plots within run
to run variants
we need to back this off to try and get
a little more performance out of it
to see an actual uplift consistently the
3060 ti
operates 10 fps below the 30 70 so the
30 70 keeps its 14
lead from elsewhere the rx 6800 jumps to
a 25
lead here previously it was closer to 20
skipping a resolution to 1080p
the 3060 ti ran 136 fps average with an
oc bumping to 140 and the gap between
the 3070 and the 360 ti has shrunk in
here
with only a five percent advantage the
oc pushes them to rough equivalence once
again
the rx 6800 falls to a 16 lead
from 25 previously gta 5 at 4k
and with our custom bench settings had
the 360 ti at 65fps average
improving to 67 with the oc the card is
within range of the 2080 super
in both instances stock and overclocked
and it's about the same the 1080 ti ftw
3 manages to actually outperform the
stock 3060 ti-fe here so it's not dead
yet but it required a game from 2015
from 2013 to actually beat it the 30 70
maintains its advantage albeit reduced
to 10
the rx 6800 keeps its 20 lead over the
360 ti
as shown in several other titles now
that's enough of these we'll flash
through a couple more charts here like
rainbow six siege but at this point
we've established what the differences
are and they're not really going to
change that much
from the average of the averages but
feel free to pause if you want to look
at one of these in more detail we're
getting into rtx games now this testing
has four games total that we benchmark
with variations on dlss on or off
in order to provide a b comparisons with
the amd
rx used shadow of the tomb raider is
first and it has a more subtle use of
ray tracing
for shadows in that it's the least
demanding of our rt benchmarks
at 1080p the 3060 ti is 97 fps average
beat all of the 20 series cards except
the 2080 ti
the 3070 fe is eight percent ahead in
performance while amd's rx 6800 is just
four percent ahead
180 dollars for a four percent uplift is
not a great start for amd
and the ray tracing benchmarks but we've
already established previously that amd
is on the more anemic side for rt
performance right now here's the 1440p
chart
higher resolutions widen the gap but not
by much at 1440p the 3060 ti
still averaged higher than 60fps but the
3070 fe
is 10 ahead that's similar to the tomb
raider benchmarks without rtx enabled
purely in terms of percentage scaling
and is partly thanks to the relatively
lightweight rt demands of tomb raider
the 6800 did better relative to nvidia's
cards here
nearly tied with the 3070 and within
round run variants
it's 11 beyond the 3060 ti's result
as well moving to 4k confirms that
higher resolutions
favor amd here the 6800 is 14
ahead of the 360 ti a more appropriate
difference
given the prices of the two cards but
that's at just 42 fps average for the
6836 for the ti
this isn't an ideal level of performance
for actually playing the game obviously
control is the first of two games we
test using dlss which is a feature that
remains exclusive to nvidia
that doesn't strongly affect comparisons
with nvidia's own cards
with the 3070 fe for example being eight
percent ahead of the 3060 ti at 1080p
and in shadow of the tomb raider we saw
a similar lead
so this scaling thus far has been mostly
the same between the games
since amd's cards must run without the
benefit of dlss
the 6800 is relatively easily
outstripped by everything
down to the 2060 ko that is there's no
contest when the cards are compared this
way
even disabling dlss which apparently
according to our viewer base isn't
the preferred way to play this game it
does use dlss 2.0 so that's fair
even without dlss though there's still
an advantage of the 3060 ti
over the 6800 by a relatively wide 12
percent margin the 3070 fe's advantage
increases slightly with resolution so
let's move to 4k for the full effect
here the 3070 fe is 13 ahead of the 360
ti
at 47 fps versus 42 fps while the 6800
has dropped down to an
unplayable 20.3 fps average without the
benefit of dlss
the 3070 and 3060 ti have similar
difficulties
but even here the ti is 11 ahead of the
the same kind of scaling seen at 1080p
control showed predictable stock versus
stock differences for nvidia's cards
but the 6800 could not outperform the ti
in a single instance
minecraft is our second dlss enabled
game and the more punishing of the two
despite its intentionally simple art
style
dlss works well as a result of that art
style it's pretty predictable
but the fully path traced approach and
the beta status of the game
make it more abusive on the hardware at
1080p the 3070 fe demonstrated its value
more than
any of the other rtx tests so far
exceeding the 3060 ti
by a much wider 31 percent lead at 125
fps average versus 75.
without dlss the 6800 is already below
60 fps at this
resolution averaging just 41 fps but
it's not an officially supported card
with minecraft and his current beta
status so
we're more interested in that in video
comparisons here disabling dlss on the
3060 ti though
still allowed it to average 67.1 fps
which is about 67
ahead of the amd card the 3070s
advantage over the 3060 ti
is slightly less at 1440p but it's still
22 percent
the 6800 struggled along with a 25 fps
average
while the 3060 ti without dlss averaged
41 fps
this is almost the exact same
performance advantage as at 1080p so
it's about 66 percent ahead
without dlss the 3070 fes lead was
reduced
now 16 ahead of the 360 ti finally at 4k
the 3060 ti
still managed 57 fps average with the
lss
while the 6800 chopped a lawn at 12 fps
average a 385 percent advantage
for the less expensive card evening
things out by disabling dlss still left
the 360 ti 61
ahead but with an unacceptable average
of 19 fps
the 3070 fe couldn't reach a playable
frame rate at these settings
either but it did score 17 percent
higher than the 3060 ti
again demonstrating an area where the
more expensive card
has some tangible benefit quake 2 is up
next quake 2 rtx does not run on the amd
6000 series cards at all right now which
makes comparisons here a little simpler
we'll run through this one quickly the
3070 fe is back to a more reasonable 14
percent over the 30 60 ti at 1080p
and it maintains approximately the same
performance advantage at 1440p
the 3060 ti is borderline at higher
resolutions
and not easily playable at 4k with a 21
fps
average there aren't thousands of people
lining up to play quake 2 rtx
but these results and the others we've
discussed allow us to extrapolate and
say
that the 3060 ti isn't the card for 4k
gaming with rtx enabled so
not much of a surprise there but
relative to the 3070 we've given you
some numbers
to help determine whether or not the
differences really matter they start to
emerge more here
than they did in the pure rasterization
based games power benchmarks are up next
we use a physical hardware interposer
for this testing that measures power
into the pcie slot
and pcie cables combined this gives us a
total card power consumption
and so it's isolated from the system
power consumption
if you add our gpu numbers for power to
our cpu power numbers
you have a pretty good guideline for the
maximum power consumption of the two
most demanding components in the system
there's more to it than that obviously
but that at least gives you a starting
point
for the type of power supply you should
be in the range of and then
have some buffer for fans and everything
else we'll start with the power virus
workload for power draw
in furmark the rtx 3060 ti fe stock card
pulled about 202 watts during this test
which has it about equal to the evga rtx
2070 xc when it was overclocked
also at 200 watts or about 16 percent
more power
than the rtx 2070 xc when it was stock
compared to the 360 ti fe stock card the
30 70 fe stock card pulled about 11
percent more power
with the rx 6800 at about 18 more power
consumption
in our gaming workload things didn't
change very much the 3060 ti
fe pulled about 200 watts stock and
about 10 more with the oc
roughly congruent with the power budget
increase permitted on the fe card
we haven't highlighted the 3080 fe on
these charts yet
so let's go ahead and do that the 3080
fe pulled out 321 watts in this workload
boosted over the 360 ti by about 120
watts
that's enough for a potential power
supply change but the 360 ti
and 3070 are close enough that you'll be
in a similar class of power supply
closing it out then opinions are once
again it's
there's nothing to compare it to so we
don't really have a strong opinion
either way it's not like a
if we had another 400 card from nvidia
or amd
to compare it to other than the 20
series which was kind of boring in a lot
of ways especially this price class
the 2060 ko was actually really cool but
not for the reasons that
cards are supposed to be it was it was
cool because
nvidia had a second skew of the 2060
that was
a 2080 with things turned off except
they forgot to turn off some of the
features that made it really good
and things like production workflows so
that's why that one was interesting
but compared to the 20 series you know
you for the most part
if you're on 20 series yeah it's a big
jump
but unless you really feel like your
experience is terrible with the card you
have and you hate it
it'd probably skip a generation it's
just wasteful to
upgrade from 20 to 30 series it's a big
jump yes
but unless you really specifically want
something like maybe
specifically higher rate tracing
performance that's like the one thing
you really care about maybe you do
optics or something like that where you
do a lot of plans to do a lot of ray
trace gaming
then it makes sense but if you're just
looking at it going
it's new that's not really good enough
reason here we think it's it doesn't
stand strong enough on its own the 3060
ti especially
to justify a jump from most of the 20
series
a jump from the 2060 ko yes is is
huge in some of these benchmarks where
it's up to 50 percent of an improvement
but short of that if you're on 20 70 20
80 super
uh it might feel a little bad to get
outclassed so fast
but it's also it'd be a side grade to be
a lateral move
not worth changing the device you're on
and even the 2060 ko if you're not
increasing your resolution past 1080
especially or 1440 in some cases
then probably stick with it if you're on
an older card 10 series
900 series and it's starting to show its
age and
gaming performance or whatever it is you
use it for cuda otherwise
not optics at that point then the 30
series makes sense
but it's just it's kind of again it's
hard to draw a conclusion with a 360 ti
because there's not an immediate
adjacent competitor
from amd and from nvidia the closest
thing is the 3070
and the reason it's hard to draw a
conclusion for any of this
is because the prices are all made up
and don't matter
so that's not because they're
in any way like fake prices it's because
you can't really get the things the
chances of getting them is very low
so demand is stupid high right now
the chance of rolling the dice and
getting a card not great
and so doing comparisons it sort of
feels like well what's the point
but if we're going to try and force a
comparison the 3070
is on average about 11 to 15 percent
better
than the 30 60 ti and pure rasterization
performance
it sometimes falls to about eight and a
half percent eight percent in 1080p
at 144k you're looking at 11 to 15
on average for the 30 70 versus the 360
ti
is that worth 100 it's up to you
probably not
but especially because you can overclock
it in
in cases where roc was stable because uh
we saw uplift of you know eight ten
percent in some of the higher end
scenarios you're encroaching on 30 70
territory anyway
and yes you can overclock the 30-72 in
response to that and maintain the
distance
but if you're going for 30-70 baseline
stock performance you can get that
pretty close to it anyway with the 3060
ti not quite
but it's close enough now for
ray tracing the differences are about
the same for the most part the scaling
hierarchically you're seeing 11 percent
in some of these games uh eight percent
some resolution some games but that's
about the gap versus the 30 70.
where's the 6800 the 3060 ti is
superior where specifically it has dlss
access in rtx games but the 360 ti
gets destroyed in rasterization
performance where it's 20 to 25 percent
lead
for the rx 6800 non-xt
that however does kind of make sense
because the pricing is much higher on
the 6800
so is there even a point to making that
comparison well
perhaps not beyond helping someone who's
unsure how much to spend
and knows more just what kind of
performance they want then it might help
but if you know what you're going to
spend
you'd probably on average not stretching
that budget another 200
for the card or whatever the price may
be for the 6800s right now
so yeah that's it for this one uh we're
gonna leave you the numbers and let you
figure it out because at this point
it's it's the market is very strange and
difficult to compare and contra
contrast with because it's it's not
normal for there to be
uh so much demand and low chance of
getting a device
at this stage in the launch cycle this
is an exceptional year for that
so makes it tough but you've got the
numbers figure it out
uh we'd say overall meh it's compared to
the 2080 super yeah
good performance a lot cheaper for the
2080 super 1080 ti in modern day via the
36 dti
you've got a memory reduction but
performance is similar in gaming so
that's cool
but the rest of it's just kind of meh so
that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe for more you can go
to store.camerasaccess.net to help us
out directly
or patreon.comgamersnexus and we'll see
you all next time
the